dan bon Gino is a former Secret Service
agent and NRA TV contributor he's also
author of the books spy gate the
attempted sabotage of Donald J Trump
and Dan joins us now would you if you
were in the president's position would
you agree to sit down with mala hack
know why
Marc why why should he sit down with
mother his case is based on nothing
Marco let's walk this through let's be
logical for many liberals have a
difficult time with this right but this
entire case as we know it is based on
this dossier this spurious nonsensical
dossier let's walk through with the FBI
themselves said about the dossier the
director of the FBI said the information
was salacious and unverified the number
two said they would have no
investigation without the dossier the
head of the division in charge of the
case said the verification of the
dossier was in its infancy and the lead
investigator in the case said there's no
there there right why would you why
would he sit down with this guy this is
obviously a trap he did nothing wrong
well as you say that's all logical and I
would buy that if you know if somebody
was trying this with mr. Smith at the
county court but what about the politics
of this I mean half the country is going
to go bananas
if Trump refuses to sit down with mother
so in other words it's the risk of
walking into a perjury trap less than
everybody claiming Trump's pulled off a
coup because he won't sit down with this
cockamamie guy wants to talk about some
lousy Steele dossier you know it's a
great point Marc there are different the
political price and the legality of it
are two different arguments on the
political front which you ask yes there
will be a price but here's the problem I
have with that mark if I thought Muller
was acting in good faith I would say all
right maybe it may be worth doing it
then at that point if it's limited in
scope the problem is marked there's no
evidence of that Mike Flynn sat down
with investigators from the case with no
lawyer in the White House to the FBI one
back admitted that there were no signs
of deception
they then prosecuted them for what for
lying to the FBI does that make any
sense
there's no good-faith effort here at all
no and I'm at
absolutely opposed to this whole lying
to the FBI thing I think that's
disgraceful
dan I don't want to get this in because
despite allegedly being under Russian
control president Trump's administration
has just slapped new sanctions on Russia
in response to the nerve agent poisoning
of a former Russian agent and his
daughter in the UK and the sanctions
will kick in later this month actually
an another young woman over in Britain
subsequently died of this poisoning so
Trump is acting against Putin because
Putin's poisoning and in fact killing
the citizens of American allies what do
you make of this yeah mark if Trump is a
Russian asset being controlled by Putin
he is certainly the worst Russian asset
in the history of human inhuman
intelligence gathering his military
wiped out 200 Russian mercs on a Syrian
battlefield he has led the effort to cut
off the Nord Stream to pipeline to
economically damaged Russia Magnitsky's
expanded that I mean mark listen what
we're having conversations like we're
rational because we are but trying to
get through the six inch thick skull of
liberals who have committed to this
Russian collusion thing is useless
nothing we say is gonna make a
difference facts don't matter anymore
all that stuff you said Dan all that
shows is that the conspiracy just goes
deeper than any of us could possibly
suspect our dad bought Gino